one of the most amazing things about
atoms is that they are mainly empty
space if an atom were as wide as your
arm span then the electrons would all be
whizzing about inside the volume
enclosed by your fingertips meanwhile
the nucleus would be sitting in the
center and its diameter would be smaller
than the width of a single human hair so
all of the atoms that make up you and me
and all the seemingly solid things in
the universe are mostly empty space now
this is incredible but what is even more
mind-boggling is that empty space is not
truly empty I know because I've seen it
this is a simulation by Professor Derek
line Webber at the University of
Adelaide it was made using a
supercomputer to crunch the calculations
of quantum chromodynamics now that is
the theory of fundamental particles
called quarks the building blocks of
protons and neutrons and how they
interact with each other through gluons
what you're looking at here is the
energy density of one field fluctuations
where the red spots come out of the
energy density is very high fades down
from the color so in the lowest energy
field fluctuations are not rendering
this animation so that we can actually
see into it and what we see is a
bubbling soup of quantum field
fluctuations that come and go incredibly
quickly the frame rate of this
simulation is 1 million billion billion
frames per second now that is truly
high-speed the dimensions of this box
are absolutely tiny they are millionths
of a billion of a meter roughly enough
space to stick to protons but there are
no protons here this is a simulation of
the vacuum on its own where we normally
think of as empty space empty space is
actually full of these cork long field
fluctuations and on average it is
possible to annihilate a cork from empty
space because it's not
it just sounds like the most ridiculous
idea that you you're meant to have empty
space in it you can go and get rid of
stuff from that's right so it is empty
now it seems counterintuitive that the
vacuum at its lowest energy state should
contain all of this stuff but in fact to
clear out the fluctuations and create a
truly empty vacuum would require a lot
of energy the empty vacuum actually
costs an enormous amount of energy to
create and you were able to create it
you discover that it's actually unstable
that any sort of perturbation would push
that empty vacuum into something where
the vacuums actually full of
fluctuations well this may not be as
strange as it first appears I mean
consider a permanent magnet it has a
magnetic field around it at low energy
at room temperature and that's because
the individual little magnetic moments
of all the atoms inside are lined up but
if you were to heat it up you would give
thermal energy to all those particles
and at a certain point called the Curie
temperature they would be so randomly
aligned that there would no longer be an
overall magnetic field so it actually
takes energy to get rid of the permanent
magnetic field and this is just like the
quantum vacuum and understanding how the
quantum vacuum fluctuations work gives
us a sense of what the fundamental
particles do like where are you most
likely to find a cork and it turns a or
likes to sit on top of those lumps now
those lumps come into and out of
existence fairly quickly and so we like
to think of the quarks is hopping from
one love over to the next lump as it
appears and the not another one I like
to think of it it's - trying to cross a
stream that's running around every now
and then a stone pops up it's the water
swirling rabbits they put your foot
there and you look for the next spot go
quickly enough you might not get your
feet wet so I think quarks are very much
to what we know for server to much doing
the same thing so while it is true that
you and I and all of the other atoms in
the universe are mostly empty space
it is also true that
empty space isn't truly empty and in
fact it is these vacuum fluctuations
which are essential for our existence
if you're not subscribe to Derek's
channel veritasium I'm not what you're
doing with your life it is amazing I got
a pretty fat lip from doing this but
luckily all my teeth were intact